finding his family tree that's what
Gary's up to he was on the phone this
weekend to a church in Italy somewhere
no no no I hire I hired someone
I hired like a family tree specialist to
just some some light work and she said
that the next move is to contact the
churches in Italy but right now because
of the pandemic everything's closed
wasn't this supposed to be your hobby
during the coronavirus and now you've
outsourced it to someone else I mean
well you can only get so far you can
only get so far so outsourced stood in
the sense where she's guiding me on what
to do next
what are you gonna do next I'm actually
I'm actually trying to see if I could
draw a line to there's a famous
Renaissance painter and we are family
always thought that we might be related
wasn't that the Guillermo de la Barthe
nicolò Dell'Abate whose paintings are
right next to the Mona Lisa in the
Louvre in in Paris
Gary puppeteer you you've been looking
up your family tree right I have and my
last phone call I found I had a relative
his name was John Quincy Dell'Abate he
was there during the Revolution he
shoveled the [ __ ] out of Paul Revere's
horses stable all right very very
important I think most people go through
these family trees hoping that there's
some greatness in their family line
that's the whole life oh yeah I'm afraid
that I'm gonna find out that you know
that my relatives were I'm not related
to the paint I'm related to [ __ ]
thieves who were did horrible things by
the way my great-great-grandfather
Luciano Dell'Abate had the biggest
trampoline in Napoli is that right and
then there was Hershey de Levante the
the inventor of the chocolate chip you
know what the sad thing about Gary's
family tree is Gary is the greatest
Dell'Abate in the family that's right
we've already found him there's no
Ganga's Khan Dell'Abate
[Laughter]